qui faut d'abord retenir de ce conseil
des ministres entièrement consacrée à
l'épidémie
c'est que le chef de l'état estime que
la voie suivie et la bonne un
gouvernement qui veut réussir le
déconfinement après les critiques et les
imprécisions dans sa gestion de la crise
alors la porte parole du gouvernement si
bête ndiaye a annoncé qu'un hommage
serait rendu le 14 juillet lors de la
fête nationale aux soignants et puis
légion d'honneur sera attribuée aux
personnes qui se sont montrés
particulièrement dévoué pendant cette
crise
la porte parole du gouvernement est
également revenu sur ce groupe de la
majorité un qui veut créer un nouveau
groupe de marcheurs à l'assemblée
nationale je propose de l'écouter
si tel était le cas je ne peux que
regretter que le ferment de la division
soit à lèvres dans une période je vous
le dis je vous le répète qui est
absolument exceptionnel alors même que
nous aurons des discussions à avoir à
l'intérieur de la majorité évidemment
sur ce que sera la fin du quinquennat et
sur la manière de nous relancer
l'activité dans notre pays sur les
réponses que nous aurons à apporter dans
la suite de cette crise il apparaît donc
que c'est véritablement là un
contretemps pour ne pas dire qu en
contresens politique
une autre annonce de ces bêtes ndiaye
cette fois ci concernant les parcs et
les jardins en ile de france
malgré les demandes répétées de la maire
de paris anne hidalgo d'ouvrir à nouveau
les parcs et les jardins à paris le
gouvernement répond non ce n'est pas
opportun le gouvernement veut se montrer
prudents et veut gérer ce déconfinement
alors que le nombre de décès liés aux
cures navires us repart à la hausse en
ce troisième jour de déconfinement